Hallo und herzlich willkommen zum Chaosradio 269, das kurz und prägnant Geld, Kunst und die Lösung all unserer Probleme heißt. Und ihr werdet vielleicht schon mitbekommen haben, wenn es um die Lösung all unser Probleme geht, dann kann es sich bei dieser Sendung nur um die Blockchain handeln. Oder fünf, mal sehen, das werdet ihr im Laufe der Sendung noch herausstellen. Wir reden also heute über diese Technologie, die immer wieder mal durch die Nachrichtenwellen schwappt. Meistens, wenn Bitcoin ein neues Hoch hat. Und dann habt ihr vielleicht ab und zu, also in meiner Teilen ist das so, NFTs ist so ein Begriff, der rumschwimmt, irgendwas mit Kunst und Blockchains. Und dann ist ein weiteres Thema, was man ab und zu mal hört, so, Länder große Mengen von Energie werden für das Erstellen von seltsamen Digitalwährungen erstellt. Diesen ganzen Themenkomplex wollen wir uns heute mal angucken. Und wir machen das sehr selten bei Chaosradio. Aber heute ist vielleicht eine Sendung, wo ein bisschen Vorwissen gefragt wird. Also wir versuchen, das alles noch wirklich auch mitzuliefern, aber wahrscheinlich nicht sehr ausführlich. Das ist aber nicht so schlimm, weil es gibt ein Chaosradio, wo wir das schon mal in den Grundzügen geschaffen haben. Das ist das Chaosradio 169, glaube ich. Es ist genau 169, das ist also 100 Sendungen her. Damals haben wir als Bitcoin noch relativ neu war, genau darüber gesprochen, und sozusagen ein bisschen von den Grundlagen, sowohl technisch als auch dieses, was ist eigentlich ein Krypto-Geld oder eine Kryptowährung, das ist da schon so ein bisschen erläutert. Wenn ihr also ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz neu in dem Thema seid, könnte es sinnvoll sein, das zuerst zu hören. Jetzt begrüße ich aber die Gäste der heutigen Sendung, das sind Peter Leppelt, hallo.
Hallo.
Max Haarich, hallo. Und Andreas Bogk, hallo. Ich kann mal bei Andreas mal anfangen. Den kann ich sozusagen kurz vorstellen und sagen, Andreas war schon mal hier, nämlich in der Sendung 169. Er ist sozusagen Resident Hacker im Chaos Computer Club Berlin oder im Chaos Radio, was wir hier in Berlin aufnehmen und war damals bei dem Thema schon dabei. Andreas, aber sag doch mal, wer bist du eigentlich, was machst du und was hast du mit Blockchain zu tun?
Ja, ich bin Andreas, hast du schon gesagt. Hacker seit langer, langer Zeit, das ging mal in den späten 80ern los, als ich Teenager in Berlin war und im Haus der jungen Talente fleißig Software kopierte. Als das noch erlaubt war, weil noch die DDR da war, bin ich dann nach der Wende in den Chaos Computer Club reingeschwappt.
Die Kurzfassung, nur die Kurzfassung.
Das ist die Kurzfassung. Und mache seitdem Dinge mit Computern. Was habe ich mit Blockchain zu tun, das ist gerade erzählt. Vor zehn Jahren habe ich mir das mal angeguckt, habe dann viel drüber geredet. Und ja, mein Mann hat es abgegeben, es nicht geschafft, damit reich zu werden.
Okay, mal gucken. Du bist aber aktuell, du verfolgst das sozusagen.
Ich verfolge das als interessierter Beobachter, ja.
Verstehe, verstehe. So, was kann ich über Max sagen? Max ist Konsul, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, und hat eine Serie von NFT-Zertifikaten, mit denen er sich gegen potenzielle Auktionsgewinne absichert. Sag mir zumindest die Wikipedia. Max, wer bist du und was hast du mit Blockchain zu tun?
Das trifft schon ganz gut. Also, Max bin ich, komme eigentlich aus Aachen, bin Konzeptkünstler und Ethikberater und als Diplomat für die litauische Künstlerrepublik Užupis unterwegs, für die ich Brücken zwischen Kunst und Technologie baue, um eben ethische Debatten anzustoßen und die Themen für die Bevölkerung greifbar und gestaltbar zu machen. Und eigentlich ist mein Fokus künstliche Intelligenz, weil da sehr, sehr spannende Fragen aufgeworfen und diskutiert werden. Und aktuell ist natürlich auch bei NFT da sehr, sehr viel Spielraum und Möglichkeit geboten, wichtige Menschheitsthemen zu diskutieren. Deswegen habe ich mich diesem Thema gewidmet.
Du musst noch mal ganz kurz erklären, also wirklich nur kurz. Was ist deine Künstlerrepublik?
Eine Künstlerrepublik, also ganz konkret Užupis, ist ein Stadtteil in Litauen, in Vilnius, der Hauptstadt, der sich selbst zur Künstlerrepublik erklärt hat. Das bedeutet, da wohnen um die 7.000 Menschen, von denen sehr viele Künstler sind. Und die haben gesagt, wir erklären das jetzt zu unserer eigenen Republik mit unseren eigenen Regeln und Gesetzen und gestalten das so, wie wir möchten. Und so haben die es geschafft, nach dem Zusammenbruch der Sowjetunion sich aus Gewalt und Armut zu befreien. Leider so gut hat das geklappt, dass die ganze Gentrifugation da reinschlägt und die sich wahrscheinlich bald ein neues Territorium suchen müssen.
Okay, das ist vielleicht das Thema für die eigene Sendung, aber jetzt wissen wir zumindest ganz grob, wo es herkommt. Und dann haben wir noch Peter. Peter ist zum Beispiel Autor des Artikels Hype vs. Realität, Doppelpunkt Blockchain. In Achtung, der Zeitschrift innovative Verwaltung. Peter, wer bist du und was hast du mit Blockchain zu tun?
Da hast du dir ja was ganz Einfallsreiches rausgesucht. Ja, wer bin ich? Also ich glaube, meine, nennen wir es Karriere, hat eh nicht angefangen wie die von Andreas Ende der 80er, nur halt im Westen, d.h. da war es illegal. Ansonsten habe ich dann irgendwann auch Informatik studiert, habe einen zweiten Bildungsweg, habe dann irgendwann zwei Firmen gegründet, die sich mit Security befasst haben. Da waren wir auch eine ganze Menge Leute, deswegen schiebe ich mittlerweile eigentlich nur noch Zahlen. Seit eineinhalb Jahren renne ich so ein bisschen als freiberufliches Radikal durch die Gegend und erzähle im Wesentlichen der Politik und Unternehmen, A, was die Blockchain ist und B, rede ich sie ihnen dann aus.
Okay, gut, der Michael bei dir an der richtigen Stelle. Was ist denn die Blockchain?
Oh mein Gott.
Du hast es gesagt, ich benutze es nur.
Ja, warum mache ich das, warum mache ich das, auch frage ich. Ja, okay, also die ganz schlanke Version in einem Satz oder? Ja.
Kann ich nicht. Ich habe eine Erklärung in einem Satz, die ist aber nicht hilfreich. Es ist ein degenerierter Märklebaum.
Vielen Dank, vielen Dank, okay. Jetzt für alle Leute, die nicht wissen, was ein Märklebaum ist.
Das ist richtig und komplett hilfreich.
Wir versuchen es vielleicht mal mit drei Sätzen und holen ein bisschen aus. Wir fangen damit an, was ist ein Hash? Das ist so eine Art Prüfung. Man kann also einen großen Haufen Daten nehmen und dann kann man daraus einen kleinen Haufen Daten machen. Dieser kleine Haufen Daten ist so etwas wie ein Fingerabdruck des großen Haufen Datens. Mit der Besonderheit, dass wenn man die Fingerabdrücke vergleicht bei kryptographischen Hashes, von denen wir hier reden, auch die großen Datenhaufen mit sehr, sehr hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit gleich sind. Also wir können Prüfsummen bilden. Lass mal den Märklebaum mal weg, das führt zu weit. Was ist eine Blockchain? Eine Blockchain ist, ich habe hier drei Datenhäufchen und jetzt nehme ich die drei Datenhäufchen, mach davon meine Prüfsumme. Jetzt habe ich drei neue Datenhäufchen. Von denen nehme ich jetzt auch die Prüfsumme, aber ich nehme die Prüfsumme der ersten drei Datenhäufchen da mit dazu. Das heißt, ich habe die Prüfsumme von dem Häufchen davor, den drei Häufchen davor, ich habe meine neuen drei Häufchen mit der Prüfsumme dazugeben, eine neue Prüfsumme. Jetzt fange ich an, mache wieder meine drei Datenhäufchen und die Prüfsumme von den drei Häufchen davor mit rein, dass ich quasi immer, jedes Mal, wenn ich so einen Blog nenne sich das, bilde, die Prüfsumme von dem Blog davor mit reinnehme und dazu die Prüfsumme von den neuen Daten dazukommen. Wozu mache ich das? Das mache ich dazu, dass ich sozusagen jederzeit zeigen kann, dass alles, was davor passiert ist, bevor mein aktuelles Datenhäufchen zusammengestellt wurde, Bestandteil der Geschichte ist. Und ich kann die Geschichte nicht fälschen, ohne dass sich die Prüfsumme ändert der Blogs darin und damit auch die aktuelle Prüfsumme. Jetzt haben wir digitale Währung, da kommt ein bisschen was dazu.
Bevor wir dahingehen, dass es Währung wird, noch eine Frage. Blockchain ist ja sozusagen so was Verteiltes. Das heißt, die Prüfstunde macht dann nicht nur einer, sondern das machen alle TeilnehmerInnen.
Ja, da kommen drei Sachen zusammen. Also das, was üblicherweise als Blockchain bezeichnet wird, sind eigentlich drei Technologien auf einmal. Das ist das, was ich gerade erklärt habe. Diese sogenannten Chained Hashes, die verketten Hashwerte, die verketten Prüfsummen, als Sonderfall eines Märklebaums, der das als Baum macht, statt als Kette. Dazu kommt Technologie Nummer zwei. Das ist eine verteilte Datenbank. Alle schicken allen jeweils die Datenhäufchen zu und alle speichern diese Datenhäufchen auf ihrer Festplatte ab und alle gucken, ob die Check-Summen auch stimmen. Das heißt, wir haben ein großes Netz, in den Knoten drin sind, jeder schickt sich gegenseitig alle Daten zu, alle Daten werden überall gespeichert, damit alle dasselbe haben und dann hat der Prüf-Summe über die Blockchains geguckt, ob das auch wirklich stimmt, dass alle dasselbe haben oder nicht. Das ist Teil 2, ein dezentraler Datenbank. Und dann, um daraus eine digitale Währung zu bauen, damit man Kokain im Internet kaufen kann.
Immer gleich aufs Schlimme.
Ja, man muss ja mal benennen, wofür diese Technologie gebaut wurde. Also warum diese Kombination von Technologien mal entstanden ist. Kommt ein dritter Teil dazu. Das ist, dass alle diese Menschen, die Netzwerke betreiben, sich gegenseitig ihre Daten schicken, einer Meinung sein müssen, was denn jetzt in dieser Blockchain drin schicken, was nicht. Also ein so genannten Distributed Consent Algorithm. Also verteilter Konsensalgorithmus. Und das ist das, wo eigentlich das Bitcoin, diese Blockchain-Technologie einen ziemlich interessanten technologischen Wurf gemacht hat. Und zwar funktioniert das so, dass man nicht nur einfach den Hash-Wert bildet, sondern der Hash-Wert muss auch eine bestimmte Eigenschaft haben. Es ist also nicht möglich, ihn einfach zu berechnen, sondern man muss ganz viele Rechenleistungen reinstecken, damit diese Prüfsumme auch gültig ist. Und diese Rechenleistung, die wird durch das Netz so ausbalanciert, dass im Schnitt alle, die daran beteiligt sind, alle zehn Minuten einmal so eine Checksumme finden. Der erste, der es berechnet hat, schreit, hier, ich habe die neue Checksumme. Alle prüfen das, sagen, okay, dann machen wir jetzt ab da weiter. Und das ist dieser verteilte Konsent-Alborithmus. Also man steckt sozusagen Rechenzeit rein und je mehr Rechenzeit man reinsteckt, desto größer ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass man der ist, der dann alle zehn Minuten tatsächlich auch die Prüfsumme bildet und im Netz mitteilt, ja, ich war es, ich habe es gefunden. Und da gibt es dann auch eine Belohnung hinterher. Das ist so ganz grob der Abriss der Technologie.
Genau, ich habe die Sachen mit dem einen Satz vielleicht zu wörtlich verstanden. Genau, ich würde dazu vielleicht noch die funktionale Ebene hinzufügen. Also das was, also wie soll ich sagen, wie man es den Leuten vielleicht beibringen kann, was es grundsätzlich ist, ist eben die Beschreibung, die Andreas eben schon genannt hat, nämlich eine dezentrale Datenbank, die furchtbar langsam ist, die furchtbar wenig die Speicherkapazität hat und wie absäudo-revision-sicher ist, da ist immer auch das Problem mit der Anzahl der Knoten, also sprich der, der 51% owned hat gewonnen, aber im Wesentlichen reduziert sich darauf, also eine furchtbar langsame dezentrale, möchte gern revisionssichere Datenbank.
Also ich glaube, es ist noch verständlich, beinahe vielleicht auch nicht, aber um es noch mal eins auseinanderzuziehen, sind fast revisionssicher. Also Andreas hatte gerade gesagt, da müssten sich alle einig sein, aber je mehr Rechenzeit man reinsteckt, desto eher ist man derjenige, der die neue Prüf-Summe findet, die sozusagen an die Chain hinten drangehängt. Können wir ja mal bei dem Bild bleiben, auch wenn es dann irgendwie ein Wirklichkeitbaum ist.
Ein degenerierter Baum, der wieder in der Kette ist.
Und jetzt sagst du, wer ist das genannt? Bedingt revisionssicher. Das heißt irgendwie, wenn jemand es schafft, genug Ressourcen zu kontrollieren oder Teilnehmer an diesem Berechnungssystem, dann kann er auch bestimmen, was sozusagen Wahrheit ist?
Ja, richtig. Also dann ist der Konsens halt, also die Masse macht es. So ein bisschen demokratisch das Ganze. Und dementsprechend ist es theoretisch angreifbar, wenn man entsprechend viele Knoten zur Verfügung stellen kann. Und das macht die Sache halt auch ein bisschen tricky bei Blockchains, die nicht so groß sind wie Bitcoin zum Beispiel.
Das heißt also, es ist eine Frage der Größe der Teilnehmer in den Zahlen. Das heißt bei Bitcoin, also ein weltweit bekanntes System, wo ganz viele Menschen dabei sind, ist es jetzt unwahrscheinlich, dass jemand daherkommt und einfach mal die 51 Prozent vollmacht und es übernimmt. Aber es gibt viele verschiedene Blockchains. Und wenn die halt sehr klein sind, kann das schon passieren. Das ist eine reelle Gefahr dann.
Ja, zudem also einige Blockchain-Anbieter, meistens irgendwelche Unternehmen, von denen auch nie jemand was gehört hat, versuchen das ein bisschen zu lösen durch zentralistische Eingriffsmöglichkeiten in die Blockchain, was allerdings den ganzen Sinn und Aufbau der ganzen Sache konterkariert. Also das hat mit Blockchain eigentlich auch relativ wenig zu tun.
Frage noch, kann man das, also wenn das passiert, kann man das sehen von außen?
Es ist schwierig, also es ist genauso wie IT-Forensik immer, also schwierig.
Also man weiß es selber, weil irgendwelche Dinge passieren, die einem vielleicht auffallen, aber man kann es sozusagen, okay, verstehe.
Vielleicht müssen wir noch ein bisschen erzählen dazu, also wir verwenden das jetzt implizit, dass wir sagen Bitcoin, wir reden über Geld, aber vielleicht muss man es nochmal aussprechen.
Nee, nee, nee, da kommen wir noch zu. Wir reden jetzt erstmal nur über Blockchain. Wir reden erstmal nur über die Technologie Blockchain. Es gibt verschiedene Blockchains, sie sind angreifbar, je kleiner, desto besser.
Auch die großen sind da aber empfindlich. Also bei Bitcoin gab es das Problem, dass es irgendwann nicht mehr realistisch war, dass du als einzelner Nutzer jemals deinen Block berechnest und diesen Preis abholst. Deswegen gab es Netzwerke, wo man sozusagen gemeinsam an einen Block rechnet und dann bekommt man Anteile ausgezahlt, wenn mal ein Block errechnet wird. Diese Blockchain-Berechnungszentralen sind so groß geworden, dass an irgendeinem Punkt schon so weit war, dass wenn zwei davon sich zusammengeschlossen hätten, die die Mehrheit gehabt hätten. Also auch Kapitalismus neigt zur Monopolbildung. Das ist auch da der Fall.
Okay, genau. Und jetzt war der eine Punkt, der mir fast schon wieder entfallen wäre. Was Peter gerade gesagt hat, das haben wir nämlich noch nicht explizit gesagt, die ursprüngliche Idee hinter der Blockchain ist schon auch, dass es dezentral ist.
Ganz unbedingt sogar. Ich bin ja fassungslos gewesen, als jemand mit der Idee von der Private Blockchain um die Ecke kam. Da habe ich herzlich gelacht, als ich es das erste Mal gehört habe. Also dieses Angrussszenario, mehr als 50 Prozent der Knoten zu ownen und damit dann halt entsprechenden Schindluder zu tun, das ist halt systeminherent. Insofern war jedem die Gefahr klar grundsätzlich. Und einige versuchen das zu lösen, damit, dass sie die Blockchain auf von ihnen selbst kontrollierten Servern packen, und zwar die komplette Blockchain. Und dann gibt es eigentlich überhaupt keinen Grund mehr dafür, die Blockchain überhaupt einzusetzen. Dann packe ich da eine Datenbank hin und gut ist, wenn ich die Server sowieso kontrolliere, dann ist das die viel bessere Technologie.
Okay, aber dann können wir nochmal zurückgehen und sagen, also das war die grundlegende Idee, wir schaffen ein System, was dezentral ist, was eben sozusagen einer zentralen Steuerung und deswegen auch vielleicht im zentralen Missbrauch widerstehen kann, wo einfach man als Gesellschaft oder Community nachweisen kann oder in einem ewigwährenden Buch aufschreiben kann, wer was wohin transferiert hat. Erstmal unabhängig vom Zweck, war das die grundlegende Idee?
Also tatsächlich war die Idee, damit Geld zu bauen, das nicht von der Zentralbank gesteuert wird, Treiber der Technologie. Also alles, was wir heute sehen an, was man mit der Blockchain noch so machen könnte, ist im Anschluss passiert. Also die Idee, wir machen digitales Geld, die stand am Anfang. Und dann kam die technologische Innovation Proof of Work, um einfach einen dezentralen Konsensalberhythmus zu bauen. Muss man vielleicht auch noch mal kurz dazu sagen, heutzutage gibt es auch andere Ansätze, die über, ich stecke ganz viel Rechenleistung rein hinausgehen. Da gibt es so etwas wie, ich habe ganz viel Geld und deswegen darf ich im Netz ganz viel mitbestimmen. Also hat noch nicht so richtig abgehoben. Da gibt es irgendwie diese iota Leute, die es seit 2017 versprechen, mich zu fliegen bekommen.
Stopp, stopp, stopp, halt. Jetzt bin ich verwirrt. Ich dachte du redest einfach von Kapitalismus, weil ich habe sehr viel Geld und darf im Netz mitbestimmen. Das machen ja irgendwie Amazon, Facebook und Google.
Das ist aber im Prinzip für einen Konsensalgorithmus.
Lass uns da eine Reihe nach vorgehen. Man ist hingegangen und hat gesagt, Geld. Dann hat man also ein technologisches System gebaut, dass diese dezentrale Datenbank für Transaktionen letztlich ist. Wie ist es denn dazu gekommen, dass aus dem technischen System tatsächlich was Handelbares wurde?
Das fing mit Alpaka-Socken an. Ja, kein Witz. Also eine der ersten tatsächlichen Verkäufe mit Bitcoin war jemand, der jemand anderem für 10.000 Bitcoin ein paar handgestrichte Alpaka-Socken abgekauft hat. Und irgendwann später, also da ist lange Zeit nichts passiert, es hat so ein paar Jahre vor sich hingedüppelt und alle haben mal so ein bisschen rumgerechnet und es war ganz lustig und nett. Da gab es die Phase, wo man anfangen konnte schon so ein bisschen was dafür zu kaufen und dann gab es auch die ersten Börsen, die sich aufgebaut haben. Also ich erinnere mich, dass man in Berlin im Room 77 ein Burger und ein Bier bekommen hat. Also ich habe für 0, 3 Bitcoin ein Burger und ein Bier gekauft. Die waren sehr lecker und sehr köstlich. Damals nicht. Ich habe bloß meine Grafikkarte ein paar Tage dafür rechnen lassen. Das war ein guter Deal. Aber das hat sich dann so langsam hochgeschaukelt, mehr oder weniger. Immer wieder in Wellen, es gab immer wieder so Boom-Phasen, immer wieder so Bust-Phasen, wo die Währung gestiegen und gestiegen ist. Und meiner Meinung nach, deswegen habe ich das mit dem Kokain erwähnt, also der USP, wie man im Wirtschaftssprech sagt, die Unique Selling Proposition von Bitcoin, war einfach, dass ich damit im Internet Drogen kaufen konnte. Das muss man einfach so sagen, damit ist Bitcoin groß geworden. Die Tatsache, dass ich damit losgehen konnte und mir irgendwie mein MDMA nach Hause bestellen konnte per Post.
Wo ich dazu sagen muss, da ist die Vergangenheitsform wichtig. Mittlerweile hat ja auch die Exekutive halbwegs verstanden, wie das sogenannte Darknet funktionieren mag, zumindest grob. Und halt auch Bitcoin. Der Gag an Bitcoin ist ja auch, dass man eben das ewige Lockwai hat und das quasi das unanonymste Ding ist, was jemals erfunden wurde in Richtung Geld. Und sobald man irgendwie ein Ast in die Realität hat, sprich, sobald man ein Produkt hat, also braucht man eine Lieferadresse zum Beispiel, oder sich halt Bitcoins kauft, ist das Wallet halt auch nicht mehr anonym. Und dementsprechend gibt es jetzt sehr, sehr viele Honeypots da draußen, die halt irgendwie Waffen und Drogen verticken und die dann halt einfach die Leute einsammeln. Insofern ist, glaube ich, schon die Vergangenheitsform angemessen.
Jetzt ist es ja mit neuen Technologien immer wieder so, dass es einen vordergründigen USP gibt oder, sagen wir mal, geben mag, der dunkel ist. Aber manchmal auch so hippieske Ideen dahinterstecken. Hier zum Beispiel, wir haben eine eigene Währung, sind unabhängig von einer Zentralbank oder so. War das nie der Fall und ist sich im Nachhinein nur ausgedacht worden? Oder geht das überhaupt?
Also wenn man sich sozusagen kulturell die Geschichte davon anguckt, dann gibt es irgendwie die Illuminatus Trilogie von Robert Anton Wilson. Und da gibt es halt diese Menschen, die auf selbstgebauten Unterseebooten durch die Gegend fahren und Drogen verteilen und das mit selbst geschaffenen Währungen, die unabhängig vom Staat sind, bezahlen und damit Warenwirtschaftsverkehr betreiben. Und auch der Leviathan, das Unterseemonster, ist ja im Prinzip eine Metapher für den Staat. Also rein ideologisch betrachtet, eine anarchokapitalistische Libertäre, den Staat ablehnende Ideologie, die dahinter steckt und auch diese Cypherpunk-Kultur, aus der das alles kommt, die die Leute in den 90ern die Verschlüsseln gemacht haben, um sich gegen den Staat zu wehren, ganz stark geprägt hat.
Das waren jetzt viele schöne Worte, aber wir wissen noch nicht ganz klar, kann man daraus, hat das auch einen Nutzen? Oder andersrum, was ihr mir bis jetzt erzählt habt. Max, liebst du eigentlich noch?
Ja, ich bin auf Start und hätte da vielleicht auch ein, zwei Anmerkungen als Technikleihe zum Thema. Ich bin da wirklich nur Leihe und alles, was ich dir erzähle, könnten allerhöchstens gefährliche Halbwahrheiten sein. Aber ich bin relativ blauäugig fasziniert von dem Ganzen, vor allem wenn es darum geht in Richtung decentralized finance. Und bin da auch vor allem jetzt Anfang des Jahres mal intensiver in die ganzen Sachen reingestolpert und auf so Sachen gestoßen wie zum Beispiel PancakeSwap oder andere Sachen, wo man seine Kryptowährungen einfach mal anlegen kann für Zinsen so ab 100% aufwärts und sowas. Und ich dachte so, okay, im Vergleich dazu, wenn ich meiner Bank irgendwie meine Euros gebe, dann sagt die, vielen Dank dafür, dass du uns Geld gibst, mit dem wir dann an den Kryptobörsen spekulieren können. Und weil du so nett bist, zahlst du uns bitte noch 0, 5% pro Jahr. Und dann hast du da andere Börsen im Internet, wo dann natürlich dann die Währung entsprechend gefährlichen Schwankungen unterliegt, aber die dir einfach mal 100% aufwärts zahlt. Und da dachte ich so, jo, das ist auf jeden Fall was. Also da wundert mich sehr, dass sich das noch nicht rumgesprochen hat und dass da nicht irgendwie alles einfach rübergeht auf diese Art von dezentralen Banksystem. Und dass sich die Zentralbanken, dass die nicht schon längst eingepackt haben.
Da wäre ja meine nächste Frage. Ist es wirklich so, dass es 100% Zinsen gibt oder ist das ein Pyramiden-Pyramid Scheme, wo letztlich sozusagen an irgendeiner Stelle dann Leute hart ausgenommen werden?
Also bei den Sachen, die ich da beobachte, das ist meistens immer nur für eine bestimmte Zeit gegeben. Es kommt immer darauf an, welche Währungen man anlegt. Und oft geht es auch darum, gleich mehrere Währungen in gleicher Menge anzulegen, damit dieser entsprechende Exchange, wo man das macht, Liquidität bereitstellt. Es wird ja sehr, sehr viel mit Währungen hin und her gehandelt, von der einen in die andere getauscht, um entsprechende Schwankungen auszunutzen und Gewinne zu machen. Und da ist es natürlich sehr, sehr essenziell wichtig, dass die Börse liquide ist und von allen Währungen genug Vorrat hat, um hin und her zu tauschen. Und um diese Liquidität zu erzielen, bezahlen die die einzelnen User dafür. Das heißt, wenn man dort z.B. für 100 € Bitcoin und 100 € Ethereum einzahlt, dann kriegt man entsprechende Zinsen, weil man dadurch ermöglicht, dass Leute in diesem Volumen Bitcoins gegen Ethereum und umgekehrt tauschen können. Und das ist meistens zeitlich begrenzt. Im Moment, eine Zeit lang, hat man auf einmal ganz viel für Dogecoin bekommen, weil alle mit Dogecoin handeln wollten. Und je nachdem, welche Währung da gerade neu aufkommt und sehr beliebt ist, gibt es da entsprechend hohe Zinsen. Die sind aber tatsächlich nicht fest versprochen, sondern die können sich täglich ändern.
Das ist ja das Faszinierende der ganzen Geschichte. Alles, was ich höre, ist, man kann das handeln. Das heißt, bis jetzt habe ich in der Sendung zwei Sachen gelernt. Das eine ist, man kann es im Darknet benutzen, um illegale Dinge zu tun. Und das andere, oder kann man jetzt auch nicht mehr, das andere ist, man kann damit hervorragend spekulieren. Also das Ding, das gegründet wurde, um das klassische Finanzsystem zu unterlaufen oder was anderes zu machen, hat nur die schmierigste Pustel dessen, nämlich die Spekulation ins Digitale übertragen. Kann man Blockchain zu irgendwas, ich sage jetzt mal sinnvoll, und ihr wisst wahrscheinlich, was ich damit meine, zu was Sinnvollem benutzen. Ne, ne, also schon, also nicht nur Bitcoin, sondern Kryptowährung und dann generell auch Blockchain. Also erstmal Kryptowährung. Gibt es, haben Kryptowährungen irgendeinen anderen Sinn, außer Spekulation, Spekulation zu ermöglichen?
Also ich hab von einem Freund eines Freundes gehört, dass man damit immer noch Drogen im Internet kaufen kann. Allerdings nicht mehr in so klein Teilen wie in Mengen.
Okay. Weil die Transfektionskosten sehr hoch sind. Auch auf die Gefahren, dass ich mich anhöre wie Life of Brian. Außer Drogen kaufen und Spekulation. Waffen. Außer Waffen, Drogen. Was Sinnvolles, Andreas, was Sinnvolles. Macht das an irgendeiner Stelle die Welt besser? Ich diskutiere jetzt nicht darüber, dass wir vielleicht eine andere Drogenpolitik brauchen.
Hat er recht, Botnetze. Stimmt sich zu haben dafür. Das Gute ist, da gibt es auch keinen Ast in die Realität. Da erwischt zu werden, ist relativ gering. Allerdings möchte ich noch einen halbwegs interessanten Aspekt betonen. Ich schwang hier schon ein bisschen mit, dass das aus der libertären Ecke kommt, in Richtung Cipherbank und so weiter. Und das, was Kryptowährungen respektive nehmen, beziehen wir uns jetzt mal wirklich auf Bitcoin, weil es ist eine saubere Blockchain, wenn man das so sagen möchte. Das Interessante an dem Ding ist, dass die Geldmenge nicht manipulierbar ist. Durch eine Zentralbank, durch einen Staat, das macht es interessant, finde ich, gesellschaftlich. Interessant meine ich jetzt hier wertneutral. Ich weiß nicht, ob das gut ist oder schlecht, aber es ist zumindest interessant, weil wir so etwas vorher so noch nicht hatten.
Also es gibt nur eine bestimmte Menge. Aber ist das nicht Augenwischerei? Weil es gibt nur eine bestimmte Menge von Bitcoins. Das sind, ich weiß es gar nicht mehr.
21 Millionen ungefähr.
21 Millionen, so. Es gibt 21 Millionen Bitcoins. Aber weil es eine Digitalwährung ist, lässt sie sich ja hinten raus beliebig fein aufspalten.
Nein.
Genau, 8 Stellen hinter dem Komma. Du kannst also 0, 00000001 Bitcoin jetzt irgendwie kaufen. Und der Wert steigt ja unfassbar. Vor einem Jahr war der eine Bitcoin 8500. Jetzt ist er gerade bei 47.500. Das heißt, wenn die so stark schwankt im Wert zu anderen Währungen und beliebig kleinstückelbar ist, hat das dann noch eine Auswirkung. Wenn man sagt, es gibt aber nur eine feste Menge?
Naja, diese ganze Spekulationssache. Also ich meine, grundsätzlich ist Geld oder eine Währung immer etwas, woran andere Menschen glauben. Also das gilt für Bitcoins, das gilt für die vier Währungen genauso. Also ein Bäcker nimmt halt nur meine Euroscheine, weil er davon ausgeht, dass er morgen für dieses Papierzeug, was er da bekommen hat, noch irgendwas anderes bekommt. Das ist der einzige Grund dafür. Und solange genug Leute an den Euro, den Dollar, den Yen oder eben an Bitcoin glauben, wird das auch funktionieren. Das Problem ist da halt, dass es eben wie gesagt nicht regulierbar ist durch eine staatliche Zentralinstanz in irgendeiner Form, zumindest die Geldmenge nicht. Man kann natürlich noch mit kapitalistischen Tricks da irgendwas machen. Dadurch ist es halt ein Spekulationsobjekt par excellence. Das kann man nicht anders sagen. Und wenn, ich sag mal, der Musk, wenn man seinen Twitter-Feed verfolgt, dann kann man daran, also anhand Hessen ja schon ganz gut, am kommenden Tag den Kurs irgendwie prognostizieren. Also es ist natürlich ein Spekulationsobjekt, gilt eigentlich für Währungen auch, aber die werden halt künstlich stabil gehalten. Deswegen ist Bitcoin halt ziemlich frei drehend.
Ich hab mich ja mit moralischen Bewertungen ein bisschen zurückgehalten bislang. Da können wir gerne auch noch drauf einsteigen. Also was wir im Prinzip sehen bei Bitcoin als Währung ist der unkontrollierte Kapitalismus eines 18. und 19. Jahrhunderts. Das heißt, es gibt keine Geldmengensteuerung. Es gibt auch niemanden, der Verpflichtungen erlässt für Geldinstitute, sowas wie Mindestrücklagen, Berichtspflichten usw. usf. Ist alles nicht existent. Und das kommt halt mit allen Nachteilen, die ein System damals schon hatte. Und all diese Fehler werden heutzutage wiederholt. Also, dass mit der Beobachtung Geld ist, wenn man daran glaubt, ist auf jeden Fall richtig. Geld ist ein soziales Konstrukt. Und das gilt, ob das jetzt Gold-backed ist oder nicht Gold-backed ist, auch der Wert von Gold ist ein soziales Konstrukt am Ende. Da annehmen sich die Währungen nichts. Aber wenn ich heute irgendwo was per Kreditkarte bezahle und der Lieferant liefert mir das nicht, dann irgendwie hole ich meine Kreditkartentransaktion zurück. Wenn mir einer verspricht, ich gebe dir 30% Zinsen und drei Monate später ist er pleite, weil er seine Bücher gefälscht hat, dann war er der entknast. Und all diese Mechanismen, die wir haben, um sozusagen den gröbsten Missbrauch eines Geldsystems zu verhindern, die sind halt bei Bitcoin und bei tiefen digitalen Währungen einfach nicht da.
Das heißt, wir haben uns in der Vorbereitung die Frage notiert, ermöglichen Kryptowährungen Kriminalität? Die Antwort darauf ist ja, aber nicht in der Art und Weise, wie man sich das vielleicht vorstellt. Aber jetzt, also, es ist ja schon so, dass, wie habt ihr gesagt, die Exekutive hat das schon mittlerweile auch so ein bisschen auf dem Schirm. Glaubt ihr, dass es...
Ich dürfte noch ganz kurz, du hast ja eben gesagt, ist das überhaupt für irgendwas anderes gut als Spekulation? Und da wäre ich auch wieder auf die Meinung der Mitredner hier gespannt, weil soweit ich das mitbekommen habe, ist natürlich gerade die Debatte, die öffentliche Wahrnehmung ganz klar geprägt von hoch. Da hat jemand vor einem Jahr Dogecoins gekauft und ist auf einmal Millionär und so weiter. Und Leute, die eben ganz viel rumspekulieren. Aber soweit ich das mitkriege, hat ja die Mehrheit der Coins und Tokens, die dort, was weiß ich, bei Coingecko oder sonst wo gelistet sind, auch fast immer noch irgendeine technische Funktion nebenher. Die Ethereum-Blockchain, die ist ja nicht irgendwie als Währung wertvoller als der Bitcoin, sondern die hat ja vor allem den Vorzug, dass sie extra auch dafür gemacht ist, Smart Contracts zu ermöglichen und eben weitere Funktionalitäten zu ermöglichen. Es gibt irgendwie Tokens, die, sei es jetzt als Governance-Token zum Beispiel, ermöglichen, dass du noch stärker bei einem Projekt mitdiskutierst. Aber es gibt auch Tokens, die gehe ich in eine Richtung von politischem Aktivismus, also ich habe einen Kollegen in New York, der hat den sogenannten DEATH-Token, D-E-T-H. Wenn man in den investiert, werden dafür Ethereum-Tokens verbrannt, einfach weil der Typ kein Ethereum mag. Gleichzeitig hat er aber auch Währungen, in die man investiert und die dann automatisch über Smart Contracting zum Beispiel benachteiligte Minderheiten unterstützen. Und es gibt auch Projekte, die über Smart Contracting zumindest geplant, irgendwann auch dafür sorgen, dass sich Wälder selber bewirtschaften können, dass ein Wald irgendwann feststellt, okay, es sind wieder genug Bäume gewachsen, ich kann jetzt wieder den Förster bestellen, die Bäume verkaufe ich dann und davon pflanze ich dann wieder neue und und und. Also ich glaube, das ist was, das ist noch teilweise in den Kinderschuhen, aber auch irgendwie noch total, das wird noch kaum beachtet, was da alles technisch noch hinter steckt, neben dieser Einzelne, neben der Möglichkeit natürlich mit Kryptowährungen zu handeln, wie man mit Baseball oder Magic Karten handeln kann oder womit auch immer Pokémon oder sonst was.
Aber was die Blockchain selber angeht, das war auch noch Teil der Frage, also jetzt nicht nur auf die Kryptowährung bezogen. Ich bin mir jenseits der Kryptowährung immer noch sehr unsicher, ob es einen sinnvollen Anwendungszweck für eine Blockchain gibt, der auch tatsächlich in der Realität stattfindet. Wir haben jetzt schon ganz viele Leute erzählt, die meisten Sachen sind Unfug, aber ich habe folgende Ideen, da haben wir uns angehört, und ich habe immer noch keine Anwendungsfalle gefunden, wo nicht eine andere Technologie besser, billiger, schneller, performanter, einfach besser erprobt ist.
Aber bei den Beispielen, die Max jetzt genannt hat, das sind ehrenwerte Gründe, die würdest du sagen, da wird Technologie auf ein gesellschaftliches Problem geworfen. Das ist aber nur deswegen Blockchain, weil sich das gerade als so ein Hype-Ding anbietet, das könnte man anders besser machen. Oder siehst du schon so, dass vielleicht wir immer noch im Frühalter der Blockchain sind und vielleicht sich irgendwann jemand sinnvolle Dinge ausdenken kann, die nicht sofort verspekuliert werden können?
Ja, das ist eben die Frage. Blockchain gibt es aktiv, verfolgt da draußen, habe ich das jetzt seit ungefähr 10 Jahren. Also Bitcoin gibt es seit 2009, wenn ich es richtig sehe, da wurde es erstmalig zumindest veröffentlicht. Und seitdem beobachte ich das so leidlich von draußen und höre mir auch die ganzen Hypes an und gucke mir das alles an. Entweder ich bin einfach zu blind und dumm, es zu sehen, oder aber es gibt einfach nichts, wo das tatsächlich Sinn ergäbe. Ich meine, eine sinnvolle Anwendungspfeife, eine Blockchain, bedarf im Wesentlichen sehr viele Parteien, die sich gegenseitig zutiefst misstrauen, sich aber trotzdem auf das gleiche System einigen, sozusagen. Das passiert überaus selten ohne Druck. Deswegen bin ich mir nicht so sicher, ob es dafür einen sinnvollen Anwendungszweck gibt, wenn ich ehrlich bin. Aber ich lasse mich da sehr gerne überraschend eines Besseren belehren. Aber bis jetzt ist mir noch keiner vor die Spüle hintergekommen.
Was Max gerade erzählt hat mit dem Wald. Ich verstehe nicht genau, was in dem Wald mit Blockchain zu tun hat. Da frage ich mich natürlich so, ist das nur eine Maskierung, fast schon eine Kunstaktion, weil man sagt, guck mal, Wald mit Blockchain. Oder, Max, weißt du da genaueres?
Also da bin ich wieder auf sehr dünnem Terrain. Also es geht vor allem da um das Smart Contracting. Und ich weiß nicht genau, inwieweit eben jede Blockchain mit Smart Contracting zu tun hat. Aber es geht bei diesem Waldprojekt, Terra 0 heißt das, da geht es um einen Wald, der sich komplett selbst verwaltet. Und dieser Wald wäre, und soweit ich weiß existiert der halt noch nicht, aber es ist mal durchgespielt, wie das aussehen würde, wäre dieser Wald komplett mit Sensoren bespickt, die alles tracken und gleichzeitig würde der sich Infos von Satellitenbildern holen. Um eben komplett automatisiert, ohne irgendwelche weiteren Eingriffe von Menschen, seine Bewirtschaftung vollziehen zu können. Das heißt, er könnte eben selber Aufträge zum Abholzen vom Wald und von Neuanpflanzen von Bäumen erteilen.
Aber das würde doch auch wieder nur funktionieren, wenn die Blockchain, die da benutzt wird, auch zum Spekulieren benutzt wird. Weil wenn ich es richtig verstehe, ist doch die Idee, dass der Wald sich selbst bezahlt. Und das geht ja wiederum nur über die Spekulation oder nicht?
Ich sag mal so, in dem Fall würde der... Ich sag mal so, das Holz des Waldes kann man ja jederzeit auch gegen eine andere Währung verkaufen. Das würde wahrscheinlich auch für Euros verkauft werden.
Okay, aber dann habe ich den Verdacht, dass es ein bisschen, wie Peter gesagt hat, das ist halt ein gesellschaftliches Problem, was wir haben. Wir haben zu wenig Wälder und das könnte man lösen. Und man kann es natürlich dann auch mit einer Blockchain lösen, aber das ist möglicherweise gar nicht die effizienteste Variante. Wir wollen später noch über den Energieverbrauch sprechen und ich weiß nicht, ob wir das dann sozusagen, konnte Greta, wird Andreas sowas noch was?
Genau, vielleicht sollten wir erstmal zu Smart Contracts noch ein bisschen was sagen. Was ist das und was hat das mit Blockchain zu tun?
Ich dachte, das ist jetzt einfach ein weiterer Datenhaufen, oder ist das noch ein spezieller?
Das ist im Grunde ein weiterer Datenhaufen, aber es ist ein sehr spezieller Datenhaufen, weil es sich bei diesem Datenhaufen um ein Programm handelt. Du hast also eine Art virtuelle Maschine mit Instruktionen drin und du kannst in deinem Blockchain einen Datenhaufen tun, der ausführbar ist. Und der, wenn er ausgeführt wird, auch wiederum neue Transaktionen der Währung in diesem System triggern kann. Das heißt, zum Berechnen der Checksumme deines Datenhaufens gehört nicht nur dazu, dass du den Datenhaufen, die Checksumme bildest, sondern dass du auch die Programme, die drinstecken, ausführst und das Programmergebnis Bestandteil davon wird. Das heißt sozusagen, dass der Konsens sich nicht nur darüber erstreckt, wer hat wem Geld überwiesen, sondern auch was ist das Ausführungsergebnis eines bestimmten Programmes, eben jenes Smart Contracts. Das klingt erst mal ziemlich clever, hat natürlich aber in der Praxis Probleme.
Kannst du, bevor du das Problem skizzierst, sagen, was kann man damit machen? Weil das kann ich mir wirklich nicht vorstellen.
Ja, ein Beispiel. Was kann man damit bauen? Versicherung zum Beispiel. Stellen wir uns mal ganz dumm, Programme haben ja immer Inputs und Outputs. Du kannst also sowas bauen, wie du kannst Geld auf ein bestimmtes Wurzelendes Konto überweisen und wenn eine bestimmte Summe Geldes zusammengekommen ist, wird die auf ein weiteres Konto transferiert, beziehungsweise wenn zu irgendeinem Zeitpunkt die maximale Summe nicht zusammengekommen ist, wird es zurück an den Ursprüngen transferiert. Also könntest du sowas wie Kickstarter damit implementieren und zwar komplett automatisiert. Du gibst ein Konto in Ethereum, da überweist du Geld hin und entweder kommt das Geld zusammen und es wird ausgezahlt oder du kriegst dein Geld zurück.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob das so funktioniert, aber so könnte man das mit dem Wald machen. Man gibt sozusagen eine Anfangssumme rein, es gibt einen Anfangswald und der verkauft sein Holz und wenn da genug zusammengekommen ist, beauftragt er neue Dinge und sagt ok, das kann ich mir jetzt hier hervorbringen.
Genau, wenn bestimmte Inputs kommen, also ist natürlich in dem Fall sowas wie Sensor Inputs in ein Stückchen Smart Contracts, sind natürlich beliebig zu fälschen. Also ich weiß nicht, wie man sowas so bauen könnte, dass es funktioniert. Die Idee ist nett. Natürlich haben Smart Contracts auch Probleme und auch Verträge zwischen Menschen haben ja mehrere hundert Jahre Geschichte und jeder, der in seinem Leben schon mal einen Vertrag unterschrieben hat, der ein bisschen komplexer war, hat da eine salvatorische Klausel drin gefunden. Da steht im Prinzip drin, falls eine Regel in diesem Vertrag unwirksam oder ungültig ist, einigt man sich darauf, dass das gilt, was wahrscheinlich laut Vertragslage wohl gemeint war von den Vertragsparteien. Das kannst du mit Programmcode nicht tun. Du kannst nicht schreiben, wenn da ein Back drin ist, dann mach halt das, was wir meinten, das geht nicht. Das hat auch schon zu Problemen geführt, weil Programme haben Bugs und da gab es gerade bei Ethereum den Fall, da haben sie tatsächlich irgendwann beschlossen, sie halten jetzt die komplette Blockchain an, das ganze Ethereum-System. Dann wurden alle Transaktionen einen Tag rückabgewickelt und der Zustand vor einem bestimmten Punkt wurde wieder in Stand gesetzt. Das ist nicht tragfähig, kein skalines Konzept, aber sie hatten keinen anderen Weg mit Bugs in einem Smart-Konzept umzugehen.
Da möchte ich noch mal hinzufügen, das ist natürlich auch ein Alptraum, weil man steckt da sehr viel mehr oder weniger ungetesteten Code in eine Blockchain, kann den nicht zurückziehen, wie eben schon ausgeführt wurde. Und der Komplexitätsgrad ist natürlich immens hoch. Je mehr Komplexität bekanntermaßen, desto schlechter ist die Security. Also das wirft ganz, ganz, ganz viele ekelhafte Probleme auf tatsächlich.
Also okay, das klingt mir alles sozusagen sehr, sagen wir mal, dynamisch. Ich habe jetzt noch zu diesem Teil Kryptowährung, Blockchain noch so zwei, drei Fragen. Das eine ist, ich habe ja schon gesagt, irgendwie Mining bei Bitcoin ist nicht mehr so, da gab es diese großen Netzwerke, lohnt es. Ich habe aber neulich bei einem großen IT-News-Nachrichtendienst eine Anleitung zum Ethereum selber meinen gelesen. Macht das überhaupt noch Sinn oder ist das eher so Hobbykram? Weil neulich gab es auch so eine Meldung, dass irgendwo eine riesige Mining-Farm aufgeflogen ist, die ja illegal war oder sowas. Also ist das für die Einzelperson überhaupt noch was, mit dem man sich beschäftigen muss?
Ich sag mal, wenn du Gamer bist und noch eine taugliche Grafikkarte zu Hause hast und Bitcoins mine möchtest, dann kannst du das tun. Das kostet halt entsprechend viel Strom. Wenn du das gegenrechnest und alles gut läuft und der Kurs hoch ist und der Mond günstig steht, dann kannst du Glück haben und gehst da halt mit, keine Ahnung, 30 bis 50 Euro pro Woche oder sowas raus. Das geht theoretisch schon.
Gibt es Gewinn oder Umsatz?
Gewinn, Umsatz wäre ganz schlecht, weil der Strom ist teurer wahrscheinlich.
Also auch da sind die Zeiten anders als früher. Ich hab dann so 2011 rum. Damals, als wir gepopcastet haben, hab ich mich tatsächlich mal hingesetzt. Dann haben wir zusammengelegt. Ich hab eine Grafikkarte gekauft, ein Freund hat einen Rechner gekauft. Dann haben wir das Ding zwei Wochen vor sich hin meinen lassen. Das stand in seinem Büro, dann war es ins Lort und hat es ausgeschaltet. Das Ding hat damals einen Bitcoin pro Tag gemeint. Die haben wir uns geteilt. Die habe ich dann irgendwann für, ich glaube, 10 Euro das Stück verkauft. Den Betrag hinter dem Komma habe ich ein paar Jahre aufgehoben. Die habe ich dann irgendwann mal für ein bisschen mehr verkauft. Aber der Gewinn war, den ich groß immer rausgeholt habe. Da ist aber auch ein Arms Race der meiner, der da läuft. Jeder versucht, die schnellste Technologie zu haben. Bei Bitcoin selbst bis zu Grafikkarten hat einfach nicht mehr Konkurrenz. Da brauchst du ASICs dafür, also speziell dafür gebaute Chips. Auch an die kommst du nicht so einfach ran, weil da wird natürlich auch wieder mit harten Bandagen gekämpft. Weil wenn du die Chips heute bekommst und nicht in drei Monaten, dann ist deine Gewinnverlustrechnung positiv. Und wenn du erst in drei Monaten rankommst für dasselbe Geld, dann ist sie negativ. Auch bei anderen Blockchains als Bitcoin, da kannst du zwar noch mit Grafikkarten meinen, aber wer gerade mal versucht hat, eine aktuelle Grafikkarte zu kaufen, der wird feststellen, dass es einfach ein Ding der Unmöglichkeit ist.
Aber liegt das tatsächlich daran, dass alle Leute gerade Chips kaufen, um zu meinen, oder liegt das an was anderem?
Tatsächlich sowohl als auch. Also wir haben gerade aktuell eine Chipknappheit, die verschiedene Gründe hat. Disruption des internationalen Warenverkehrs von Nachfolge von Covid, eine Trockenheit in Taiwan, die dazu geführt hat, dass die Chipfabriken weniger Wasser haben, durch Covid-bedingte Schwankungen der Nachfrage. Erst ist es in den Keller gegangen, dann haben alle bestellt, dann haben sie wieder bestellt und dann haben sie natürlich mehr bestellt, als sie brauchten und sind ein Haufen Effekte. Aber tatsächlich ging das mit der Unverfügbarkeit von Grafikkarten schon vor diesen Covid-bedingten Problemen los. Und gerade als Gamer kriegst du keine top-of-the-line-Grafikkarte, das geht nicht. Oder probier mal eine PS5 zu kaufen. Das hat miteinander zu tun.
Würde das besser werden, wenn alle Blockchains explodieren?
Also tatsächlich sind die Blockchains ein ernstzunehmendes Ressourcenverschwendungsproblem geworden. Also Energie, wir haben es schon mal angesprochen. Der Gesamtenergieverbrauch von Bitcoin entspricht dem eines mittelgroßen Landes. Und das wird nur mehr. Aber auch der Verbrauch an anderen Ressourcen, an Computeressourcen ist riesig. Jetzt kommen die ersten mit, die Rechenleistung durch Festplattenplatz ersetzen. Also gerade geht es los, dass SSDs knapp werden, weil Leute eine Blockchain gebaut haben, die auf der Verfügbarkeit von Plattenplatz basiert. Also dass eine absurde Ressourcenverschwendung betrieben wird.
Das wird vor allem auch immer esoterischer von der Namensgebung her. Das ist Proof of Space, dann gibt es Proof of Time, dann gibt es Proof of Time and Space und dann sind wir schon in der Science Fiction, finde ich.
Ich würde das jetzt gar nicht so sehr vertiefen wollen, aber nochmal zu dieser Energieverschwendung was fragen. Jedes komplexe System braucht ja viele Ressourcen. Und ja, Blockchain ist was Neues. Vielleicht kann man das auch noch optimieren. Das braucht momentan sehr, sehr viel. Das braucht mega viel Energie. Aber eine Frage, die immer sofort auftaucht, ist, na ja, wenn wir jetzt von der Kryptowährung sprechen, denn ein herkömmliches Währungssystem braucht ja auch sehr viel Energie. Was ich zum Beispiel ganz selten oder noch nie gesehen habe, ist, man kann dann, also Bitcoin verbraucht so und so viele Megawattstunden, aber das kostet dann eine Banktransaktion auch. Also ja, es verbraucht viel Energie, aber ist es fair, das einfach so zu sagen? Und müsste man das nicht fairerweise vergleichen mit anderen Dingen? In unserem Leben kosten auch Energie?
Muss man vergleichen, aber der Vergleich fährt halt für Bitcoin sehr, sehr, sehr ungünstig aus. Also eine Kreditkartentransaktion kostet ein Zehnmillionstel bis ein Hundertmillionstel der Transaktionskosten einer Bitcoin-Transaktion. Also für eine Überweisung Bitcoin kannst du ein Auto dreimal volltanken. Ein CO2-Fußabdruck.
Ich glaube, Bitcoin und Ethereum, das sind natürlich auch da wirklich, wie ein Freund sagte, so die Schweröltanker unter den Kryptowährungen. Ich habe es auch nur am Rande mitbekommen, aber da war jetzt auch wieder so ein Hype um Helium-Mining, was irgendwie über Radiofrequenzen laufen soll. Da kann man sich so kleine Mining-Apparate bestellen, die kosten so um die 300, 400 Dollar. Die verbrauchen irgendwie 5, 6 Watt an Strom. Und damit, da kann man sich auf der weltweiten Karte anschauen, wie viel die einzelnen Miner damit verdienen. Und da sind so gut platzierte Miner mitten in Berlin. Die machen da aktuell 10.000 Euro im Monat mit bei dem aktuellen Kurs von Helium. Und die Apparate, die sind da selbst für einen, nicht mal für einen Apparat selber, sondern einfach nur für die Sicherheit, einen vorbestellten Apparat von irgendjemanden anders sofort abkaufen zu können, zahlen andere schon das 10- bis 20-fache vom eigentlichen Preis von so einem Ding. Also das ist natürlich auch sehr, sehr davon abhängig, wie der Kursgrad ist. Aber das ist was, wo gerade aktuell eine weit, weit höhere Gewinnmarge und ein weit, weit geringerer Energieverbrauch angesagt ist als bei Bitcoin, wenn es einem darum geht, jetzt mit meinem Geld zu verdienen und möglichst noch die Umwelt nicht zu sehr zu belasten.
Also bei all dem, was wir sagen, kommt es mir trotzdem so vor, als ob es immer nur um den Gewinn geht. Also so eine sinnvolle Anwendung habe ich da noch nicht.
Ich meine, wir können jetzt mal irgendwie, wir versuchen mal sozusagen die positiven Argumente aus libertärer Sicht zu spielen. Also das gibt durchaus Leute, zum Beispiel in Venezuela, die beim Zusammenbruch der Landeswährung ihr Vermögen in Bitcoin transferiert haben und sich dann immer noch Essen kaufen konnten davon. Also das Unabhängigkeit von einer lokalen Währung, die vielleicht nicht besonders stabil ist, kann schon einen Wert darstellen.
Kann ich da noch einen Punkt? Vielleicht könnte das in die Richtung gehen, wobei ich aber auch nicht weiß, ob da Blockchain die perfekte Lösung ist. Aber was ich so mitkriege aus Amerika, dass auch gerade in der Politik da schon erste Versuche laufen, um Wahlen oder auch einfach die Meinung des Volkes zu erfassen über Blockchain, dass dort einfach zum einen Umfragen laufen, wie welche Politiker angesehen werden, dass auf der Blockchain gespeichert wird, um dort die Infos dann auch direkt in die Politikgestaltung einfließen zu lassen und es so Experimente gibt, in Richtung Quadratic Voting oder sowas nennt sich das, die einem erlauben, eine differenzierte Stimmabgabe zu tätigen. Also im Moment bei uns ist es ja so, wenn wir wählen gehen, dann sagen wir mit unserer Stimme, ich bin 100% dafür und gegen alles andere und über mittels Blockchain sind dort Sachen getestet worden, dass man eben sagen kann, ich bin ein bisschen dafür, ich bin viel mehr dafür und wenn ich noch ein bisschen Geld oder beziehungsweise von meinen Wahltokens ein bisschen mehr hinlege, überproportional mehr, kann ich auch eine bestimmte Meinung überproportional stark unterstützen. Also das sind so Prozesse, die jetzt gerade am Anfang sind und über Blockchain realisiert werden, ohne dass ich jetzt behaupten kann, dass das definitiv dafür die beste Technologie ist.
Aber das ist, ich wollte gerade sagen, ich fand das ganz interessant, für so einen Punkt, wo du gesagt hast, man kann auch ein bisschen mehr investieren, weil dann wird es wieder zu einem Spekulationserbeck. Es scheint irgendwie so da zu enden. Jetzt, ich will mal...
Es geht ja nicht um Geld, das man investiert, sondern seine Stimmen, Stimmrechte, die man investiert.
Ja, also ich glaube, der Mensch hat im Kapitalismus momentan nichts, was in diese Richtung geht und würde sagen, das kann man dann so planen, aber das wird wahrscheinlich nicht so kommen. Aber das ist vielleicht mein persönliches Misstrauen. Aber vielleicht können wir tatsächlich mal einen Schritt weggehen von den Währungen und hin sozusagen zu Blockchain. Fangen wir vielleicht mal an. Fangen wir mit dem Beispiel an. Also ich habe ja wieder gelernt heute, die Grundidee von Blockchains ist eine dezentrale Infrastruktur. Jetzt sollte es in Deutschland einen Impfpass geben, also ein wie auch immer geartetes digitales System, wo einzelne Menschen nachweisen können, sie seien geimpft. Dafür sollte es, so war zumindest die Schlagzeile, fünf Blockchains geben. Und da habe ich halt zwei Fragen. A, ein Impfpass wird ja von einer Institution ausgestellt, also einer zentralen Institution. Warum ist man auf die Idee gekommen, dafür eine Blockchain zu nehmen? Und B, was bringen mehrere Blockchains in einem System, wenn überhaupt?
Wenn ich das kurz beantworten sollte, wäre das eins, keine Ahnung, und zwei, nichts.
Ich kann das ein bisschen differenzierter beantworten. Zu eins, ich sage jetzt nicht aus welcher Quelle, aber regierungsnah und durchaus die Entscheide, die damit zu tun hatten. Ich habe damit Leuten geredet und mittlerweile haben sie mit dem Blockchain und sind ja aufgehört, ein Glück. Eins der Argumente, das da gefallen ist, das war wohl kursierte, lautete, ja, kann man zum Beispiel Ungarn als Staat vertrauen. Ja, da muss man ein bisschen um die Ecke denken. Die haben das Argument dezentral so verstanden. Es gibt ja den EU-Verbund und möchte ja gegenseitig die Impfausweise, aber wenn man sich nicht vertraut, dass es keinen Sinn macht, das war ihnen dann auch klar, als wir das mal argumentativ auseinandergenommen haben, aber das war diese Assoziation, das ist das Argument, wir brauchen was Dezentrales, weil wir ja nicht wissen, ob man der ungarischen Regierung vertrauen kann. Ist natürlich absolut nicht so. Gerade beim Beispiel Impfausweis. Man kann sich diese Dezentralität ja auch anders bauen. Man braucht ja auch nicht alle diese Features, die da drinstecken. Wir haben ja am Anfang darüber geredet, das sind Kombinationen aus drei Technologien. Wir haben die degenerierten Märklebäume, die wir eine Hash-Chain nennen. Wir haben eine verteilte Datenbank und wir haben das Proof of Work für den dezentralen Konsens. Wenn man sich das mal beim Impfausweis anguckt, ich brauche keinen dezentralen Konsens, dafür habe ich einen Staat. Die Bundesgrupperei gibt ein Zertifikat raus und gut ist. Dann können die anderen Länder in Europa auch ein Zertifikat rausgeben. Und dann erkennen sie das gegenseitig an oder halt nicht. Und dann ist es fertig, das Problem ist erledigt.
Es macht sozusagen keinen Sinn, eine Blockchain aufzubauen, die nur so viele Teilnehmer hat, wie es Daten in Europa gibt.
Genau, in dem Fall wäre es sogar noch anders gewesen. Es wären ja verschiedene Blockchains gewesen, mit einer verschiedenen Anzahl von Teilnehmern. Die haben tatsächlich eine private Ethereum-Blockchain und die öffentliche Ethereum-Blockchain, das stand da in den White Papers drin. Also völlig ohne Sinn und Verstand. Dann ist die Frage, was beweist denn ein Eintrag in so einer Blockchain? Der beweist doch bestenfalls, dass ein bestimmtes Datenhäufchen zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt vorlag. Das beweist nicht, dass das Medikament, das ich bekommen habe, echt ist. Das beweist nicht, dass derjenige, der es mir gespritzt hat, mir wirklich dieses Medikament gespritzt hat und nicht etwa eine Salzwasserlösung. Das beweist nicht, dass der Mensch überhaupt mal Arzt ist. Das beweist nicht, dass ich überhaupt da war zu dem Zeitpunkt, zu dem diese Impfung passiert ist. Das ist ja alles vollständig virtuell.
Das heißt, die Politik hat nicht verstanden, dass das Vertrauen, was eine Blockchain herstellt, nur das Vertrauen in die Daten ist, die drinstehen und nicht das Vertrauen darin, dass die Daten, die drinstehen, korrekt sind?
Genau. Und das, was wir jetzt wahrscheinlich bekommen, ist etwas, was sehr, sehr viel schlanker ist, mit sehr, sehr viel klassischerer Technologie gebaut ist. Das ist nämlich einfach ein QR-Code. Da ist ein Jason-Schnipsel, da steht drin mein Name, die Seriennummer von dem Agreement, das ich bekommen habe, ein Zweitstempel, und das ganze Ding ist unterschrieben mit einem klassischen Public-Key-Verfahren. Und fertig. Und obendrauf gibt es eine zentrale Datenbank, in der die Public Keys drinstecken, die jeweils in den Ländern freigegeben wurden. Das heißt, das Impfzentrum im Erika-Hess-Eis-Stadion hat seinen eigenen Key. Die können heute damit anfangen, diese Impfausweise, also die QR-Codes, mit dem Jason-Schnipsel, mit meinen Daten auszustellen. Und wenn dann nächsten Monat die EU soweit ist, dann laden sie ihren Public Key in diese Datenbank hoch, und der Drops-Impfausweis ist gelutscht.
Da waren so ein paar Worte drin. Also Jason-Schnipsel, sagen wir einfach, das ist eine Art und Weise, Informationen zu codieren. Und Public Key, das will ich jetzt auch nicht ausführlich erklären, da gibt es auch ein oder zwei Chaosradios zu. Das ist letztlich, sagen wir mal, eine elaborierte Art, um so eine Prüf-Summe zu generieren, die Andreas am Anfang...
Eine digitale Unterschrift, also nicht nur eine Prüf-Summe, sondern die Prüf-Summe kommt von einer bestimmten Person, und die kann ich anhand des Schlüssels ermitteln, wer das unterschrieben hat.
Okay, aber jetzt, es gab dieses Missverständnis über das Vertrauen in Daten, und generell hat man so das Gefühl, überall muss Blockchain drin sein, so wie jetzt überall KI drin sein muss. Ist das was, was einfach sozusagen klassisch fehlgeleitete Wirtschafts- slash Digitalpolitik ist? Es gibt so einen Hype, da muss halt alles damit sein. Oder ist Blockchain dafür besonders anfällig?
Ich halte das schlicht einfach für ein Memen, was da kursiert in den entsprechenden Kreisen. Also das gibt es ja, wie du schon sagtest, bei dröfzig unterschiedlichen Technologien, Buzzwords irgendwie. Aber tatsächlich ist gerade bei Blockchain sehr auffällig, bei KI auch ein bisschen, aber Blockchain in den letzten 5-6 Jahren schon sehr hart. Die Leute wissen einfach nicht, was es ist. Sie haben es nicht verstanden. Das möchte ich auch niemandem so direkt vorwerfen. Aber das Interessante ist, dass sich in politischen Kreisen die Leute meist wissen, dass andere die Technologie ebenso wenig verstanden haben wie sie selbst. Deswegen werfen sie gerne mit diesen Begriffen um sich, um a.) hip und cool zu wirken und b.) wissen sie, dass man darauf nicht festnageln kann bzw. gegenwind kommen wird. Die Leute, die auch anwesend sind, werden darüber nicht diskutieren, weil die haben das irgendwo gelesen, wissen oder denken, dass sie wissen, dass es voll sicher und hip ist. Dann ist das auch erstmal gut. Das ist eine perfekte Ausgangsbasis für PolitikerInnen. Man wirkt hip, kann nicht festgenagelt werden und dann kann man da so eine Art Gish-Gelb für Nicht-Alohüter ablegen. Man kommt einfach mit ganz vielen Buzzwords.
Das sind ja auch ganz objektiv betrachtet Leute richtig reich damit geworden. Absolut, ja. Gerade in Deutschland herrscht ja berechtigterweise ein bisschen die Panik, den internationalen Technologieanschluss zu verlieren. Wenn man sich anguckt, vor 30 Jahren gab es noch so Konzerne wie Nixdorf, Grundig, Löwe, im Bereich der Computer- und Elektronik, Technologieführerschaft, das ist ja alles verschwunden. Es gab in den letzten 50 Jahren, in Deutschland wurde mal der Computer und das Telefon der Fernseher erfunden. Solche Innovationen gab es einfach nicht. Die Fear of missing out, der ist sehr, sehr groß. Da spielt diese ganze Blockchain-Thematik prima rein. Da muss man was machen. Tatsächlich KI genau dasselbe. Damit wir die Trifecta perfekt haben, muss natürlich auch Quantencomputing mit rein.
So, jetzt haben wir schon viel über Blockchains und Kryptowährungen geredet. Das ist alles so ein bisschen aus einem Guss, hatte ich das Gefühl. Das hat angefangen, da gab es den Spekulationsmarkt, dann hat die Politik dann das Passwort und so weiter und so fort. Jetzt gibt es aber ein Thema, das in meiner Wahrnehmung hat, das damit zu tun läuft, aber so ein bisschen nebenher, also wie so nochmal so eine Parallelwelt. Das sind diese sogenannten NFTs. NFTs sind ja was eigentlich? Irgendwas mit Blockchain und Kunst. Und ich dachte, na gut, also irgendwas mit und hin, da wird es doch wahrscheinlich schnell über der Politik sein, alles heiße Luft, das platzt. Aber es scheint Dinge zu probieren, zu passieren. Und deswegen müssen wir jetzt mal herausfinden, was das ist. Und ich würde jetzt mal Max, der noch nicht viel Gelegenheit hat, zu fragen, der in seiner Eigenschaft als Künstler auch hier ist, fragen. Max, sollen wir die Technik lieber die anderen erklären lassen? Okay, gut, dann fragen wir nochmal Andreas und Peter, was sind NFTs technisch gesehen im Sinne der Blockchain? Oder was hat das mit Blockchain zu tun?
NFT steht ja für Non-Fungible Token. Das heißt nicht Tokens, auf denen keine Pilze wachsen. Schade. Ja, da wäre sie ja für was gut. Das Non-Fungible bezieht sich, also Fungible heißt austauschbar, ersetzbar. Und was das ist, ich kann dir einen Euro geben, damit kannst du was anfangen. Ich kann dir ein anderes Euro Stück geben, damit kannst du ganz genau dasselbe anfangen. Also ein Euro Stück ist gegen ein anderes Euro Stück austauschbar. Ein Geldschein hat eine Seriennummer. Das hilft dir jetzt bei einem Geldschein nicht sehr so viel weiter, aber tatsächlich, also der Geldschein ist im Prinzip auch austauschbar, aber es ist nicht derselbe Geldschein, weil er hat eine Seriennummer. Und jetzt sind fiffige Leute auf die Idee gekommen, was ist denn, wenn wir in die Seriennummer Informationen reintun? Du hast einen Geldschein, der ist aber eigentlich nicht sozusagen einen festen Geldbetrag wert, sondern der ist das wert, dass eine bestimmte Seriennummer draufsteht. Und das ist dieser Non-Fungible Token. Und jetzt gab es also diese Idee, man könne ja zum Beispiel den Besitz an einem Kunstwerk mit Hilfe eines solchen NFTs entkoden. Ist natürlich, wenn man näher hinguckt, so ein bisschen schwierig, weil, naja, da steht halt drin, keine Ahnung, ich besitze die Spinde mit den sieben Beinen, aber natürlich hindert das niemanden da dran, sich eine Kopie von der Spinde mit den sieben Beinen zu machen. Das ist halt nicht die Mona Lisa, die einmal im Museum hängt, sondern das ist ein String, wo drin steht, mir gehört die Mona Lisa. Und wenn überhaupt, dann gibt es möglicherweise ringsrum ein Vertragswerk, wo drin steht, dass mir die Mona Lisa gehört, aber das Vertragswerk geht ja nicht weg, nur weil der digitale Token weg ist. Also, ich finde es, du hörst vielleicht schon raus, ein relativ unüberzeugendes Konzept. Und es geht sogar so weit, dass also in der Praxis, steht dann also in so einem NFT, ist da nicht etwa die Mona Lisa encoded. Es ist auch nicht ein Link auf die Mona Lisa encoded, es ist ein Link auf eine Webseite encoded. Und auf dieser Webseite steht, hallo, das ist übrigens ein Anteil an der Mona Lisa. Also in dem Moment, wo die Webseite weg ist, ist auch der Besitz an der Mona Lisa weg, bei so einem NFT. Hat natürlich aber dazu geführt, dass Leute 6-stallige Millionen, 7-stallige, 8-stallige Beträge bis hin zu 100 Millionen, weil die größte NFT-Transaktion durch die Gegend geschoben haben.
Also nur noch mal, damit ich es richtig verstehe. Es gibt also eine Blockchain. Und in dieser Blockchain sozusagen sind die einzelnen Coins, oder wie auch immer man das nennen will, die da sozusagen generiert werden, enthalten auch wieder ein Häufchen Daten. Dieses Häufchen Daten ist ein Link, und zwar ein Link auf einer Website. Auf der Website steht dann, dir gehört digitales oder analoges Kunstwerk so und so.
Also wie ich mir das immer erkläre, ich sage immer, ein NFT ist wie eine Garderoben-Marke, das auf ein bestimmtes Fach verweist. Also es geht darum, das ist die Fähigkeit von einem NFT. Es kann auf etwas verweisen, und zwar auf Beliebiges. Und wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel mir vorstelle, ich habe an der Garderobe einen Mantel abgegeben, der ist 1500 Euro wert, dann bekomme ich den theoretisch sicher zugestellt, den kann ich dann auslösen über diese Marke. Wenn jemand an meinem Mantel interessiert ist, brauche ich eigentlich auch gar nicht den Mantel aus der Garderobe holen, sondern theoretisch könnte ich dem einfach mal eine Garderobe Marke für denselben Preis geben. Sagen hier 1500 Euro, kriegst du meine Marke und damit gehört dir der Mantel. Diese Person müsste mir natürlich vertrauen, dass dieser Mantel da wirklich in der Garderobe hängt, dass er das wert ist und dass man den da irgendwie rausbekommt oder auch nicht. Der Joke bei der Kunst ist, dass niemand die Kunst aus der Garderobe rausholt, sondern es im Moment nur darum geht, sagen zu können, ja, ja, das gehört mir und meistens kriegt man das tatsächliche Kunstwerk dann noch irgendwie gratis hinterhergeschmissen als Datei-Download oder Unlockable-Content.
Also das ist wieder mal nur ein Spekulationsobjekt, weil da geht es nicht ums Übertragen der Besitzrechte an etwas, sondern nur um einen Besitznachweis sozusagen. Und das ist beim Digitalen dann nochmal absurder, weil du den Mantel ja beliebig oft vervielfältigen kannst. Oder Max, kannst du mir das vielleicht erklären? Ich habe das manchmal gelesen als der Versuch, den Besitz von Kunst, der ja im Analogen ganz physikalisch stattfindet, da gibt es halt nur eins oder nur eine Serie von, das zu übertragen aufs Digitale. Ist das eine Idee dahinter gewesen?
Unter anderem definitiv. Soweit ich weiß, ist das allererste NFT, das jemals gemintet wurde. Das war so ein kleines Kunstwerk. Das wird auch gerade bei so einem großen Auktionshaus versteigert. Das ist 2017 bei einer Konferenz gemintet worden. Durchgesetzt hat sich die Technologie vor allem, um zum Beispiel Items in Computerspielen zu übertragen. Ich habe mir bei irgendeinem Computerspiel eine besonders tolle Rüstung erkämpft oder Schwerter oder sonst was und die kann ich jetzt jemandem verkaufen und übertragen. Da dieses NFT die Fähigkeit hat, auf alles zu verweisen, kann ich eben auch plötzlich Sachen übertragen, die ich vorher so niemandem übertragen kann. Niemand hätte ein Schwert, das er sich im Computerspiel erkämpft hat, irgendwie auf eine CD gebrannt, um es irgendwem zu schicken. Inwieweit das jetzt absurd ist, was da läuft, ich versuche das immer so zu vergleichen, wenn ich ein Haus kaufen würde, dann läuft ja auch erst mal nur ein Grundbucheintrag. Es kommt ja niemand, der mir ein Haus gibt, dass ich mir dann in die Hosentasche stecke. Und wenn ich mir Aktien von der Lufthansa kaufe, dann kriege ich ja auch nicht ein Stück von einem Flugzeug zugeschickt, sondern ich muss auch darauf vertrauen, dass mir dieser Teil gehört. Da gibt es natürlich die ganzen Institutionen dahinter, die das sichern, dass das alles so abläuft, als hätte ich wirklich ein Teil von der Lufthansa dann am Start. Aber im Prinzip ist das nicht viel anderes.
Und das wirft dann auch schon wieder die Frage auf, warum dann Blockchain? Also wir kommen eigentlich immer wieder bei der gleichen Frage auf. Man nimmt Blockchain, dann ist es Spekuliererei oder man macht es halt anstrengend.
Ich habe eine kurze Detailfrage zur NFT. Ist NFT eine ganz spezifische Blockchain oder ist das eine Technologie, für die es dann schon auch wieder verschiedene Blockchains gibt?
Also es gibt ganz verschiedene. Vor allem wird NFT gerade auf der Ethereum Blockchain gemintet, weil die besonders dafür geeignet war. Da beschweren sich natürlich gerade alle, dass die Transaktionskosten viel zu hoch sind. Also das kann teilweise mehrere 100 Dollar kosten. Eine Transaktion und das wäre zum Beispiel einfach nur das einmalige Einstellen eines Kunstwerks, das Minden eines Kunstwerks. Da gibt es Blockchains, wenn man das über Algorand oder über Tesos macht, da ist das dann direkt um ein tausendfaches effizienter, günstiger, auch energieeffizienter. Soweit ich weiß, soll das über Polygon sogar komplett umsonst möglich sein. Aber grundsätzlich eine Technologie, die über verschiedene Blockchains möglich ist. Angeblich auch über Bitcoin, wobei das nicht so gut geeignet sein soll und deswegen da noch nicht so viel drauf läuft.
Ich bin jetzt gerade ein bisschen sozusagen, ich laufe gerade so ein bisschen ins Leere, weil ich dachte, dieses NFT, das wird ein riesiger großer Themenblock, aber letztlich ist es halt genau derselbe Quatsch in grün. Aber Max, trotzdem mal gefragt, das ist ja, wenn wir versuchen, drüber nachzudenken, was könnte das Positives bringen? Da hätte ich jetzt den Verdacht, na ja, also im Prinzip ist ja, der Künstler, der arme Künstler, der kräftige arme Künstler, der hätte hier vielleicht die Idee, Digitalkunst zu erstellen und die auch irgendwie zu verkaufen.
Ja, also es sind gerade die Digitalkünstler, die das Geld nutzen. Also völlig abgesehen davon, dass das auch jetzt am Anfang vor allem auch wirklich als Propaganda von irgendwelchen Kryptobillionären angesehen wird, die einfach nur die ganze Menschheit in die Kryptomärkte reinziehen will. Witzigerweise ist das auch tatsächlich das, was sich beobachten lässt. Also ganz, ganz viele Leute sind gerade Anfangs des Jahres jetzt ins NFT-Business eingestiegen, haben versucht, eigene NFTs zu minden, zu verkaufen. Und wenn das nicht erfolgreich lief, haben sie dann versucht, stattdessen mit Kryptowährung Kohle zu machen. Also falls das der Plan dahinter war, hat das sehr, sehr gut funktioniert. Das Versprechen, was dahinter war, ist, genau wie du es am Anfang gesagt hast, das Durchsetzen von Urheberrecht im digitalen Raum. Zum Beispiel bietet NFT die Möglichkeit, über Smart Contracting an seinen digitalen Werken zu verdienen, auch bei Weiterverkäufen, was bisher so nicht möglich war. Das heißt, wenn Picasso sein erstes Bild damals, als er unbekannt war, für 50 Fr. verkauft hat, und das ging irgendwann für 50 Mio. weg, hat er persönlich daran nichts verdient. Jetzt kann man bei einem NFT, wenn man das mintet, direkt von Anfang an einstellen, wie viel man verdient, sobald es weiterverkauft wird. Das wird dann über Smart Contracting automatisiert erledigt. Dann werden Beträge dem Konto gut geschrieben, so dass je nachdem, wenn man eine große Sammlung hat, die eifrig gehandelt wird, durchaus ein ganz gutes passives Einkommen zustande kommen kann. NFT bietet vor allem auch am Anfang die Möglichkeit, sich selbst direkt zu vermarkten, ohne dass man als Künstlerin angewiesen ist auf große Galerien, die bisher meistens als Gatekeeper funktionieren, weil man mit seiner Ware sofort an den Markt gehen kann und sofort in der entsprechenden Community auch an erster Stelle der Aufmerksamkeit ist. Und vor allem bietet es überhaupt für Digitalkünstlerinnen zum ersten Mal die Möglichkeit, ihre rein digitale Kunst sofort zu vermarkten. Das ist natürlich jetzt auch einfach ein perfektes Timing. Man muss sich vorstellen, die Corona-Pandemie hat natürlich besonders die Künstlerinnen hart getroffen. Da sitzen ganz, ganz viele Leute zu Hause, die überhaupt keine Möglichkeit haben, auszustellen und ihre Kunst an den Mann oder die Frau zu bringen. Die haben die Festplatte voll mit Digitalkunst, die aber eben noch nicht gedruckt wird, um sie irgendwem zu übergeben. Und auf einmal bietet sich die Möglichkeit, einfach die vom Heim-PC sofort ins Internet zu stellen und über Nacht damit reich zu werden. Und das ist natürlich ein Versprechen, was sich in vielen Fällen bewahrheitet hat. In noch viel, viel mehr Fällen leider nicht. Aber natürlich sehr, sehr, sehr lukrativ ist. Und deswegen war da gerade Anfang des Jahres, als auf einmal die Preise so explodiert sind, das wurde schon angesprochen, da wurde auf einmal ein rein digitales Bild für 69 Millionen US-Dollar verkauft. Also da war natürlich der Run groß und der ist immer noch da. Also bei Facebook in den entsprechenden Gruppen sind jeden Tag Leute, die sich noch erklären lassen wollen, wie kann man NFTs machen, um damit Geld zu verdienen.
Aber ich bin gespannt, wie Sprache funktioniert. Jetzt hast du gesagt, Bild zu verkaufen. Aber es ist ja eben nicht so, dass das Bild verkauft wird, sondern es wird einen Link auf der Webseite verkauft, wo drauf steht, dem und dem gehört das Bild, oder?
Das ist jetzt eine philosophische Frage. Das ist wie mit dem Haus. Wird sein Haus verkauft oder wird da der Eintrag im Grundbuch verkauft, der verspricht, dass man dieses Haus benutzen darf? Das ist, also im Endeffekt wird nichts klassisch übergeben, so wie man im Supermarkt halt einkauft. Aber das ist man eigentlich in vielen anderen Bereichen des Lebens schon gewohnt. Aber definitiv, es wird nichts direkt übergeben.
Nee, aber beim Grundbucheintrag ist ja Folgendes. Das ist natürlich sozusagen eine Repräsentation, die da verkauft wird, aber es gibt halt eben nur ein Haus. Bei dem Kunstwerk, bei dem digitalen Kunstwerk, das kannst du ja kopieren, unendlich oft. Und dann wird sozusagen die Repräsentation wertvoller als das eigentliche Ding. Dann geht es also nicht darum, das Kunstwerk zu besitzen, also die Datei in den Händen zu halten, sondern es geht nur darum, dass irgendwo steht, dass du der rechtmäßige Besitzer bist, oder?
Ja, zum einen ist das so. Zum einen ist das natürlich sehr wertvoll, behaupten zu können, ich bin der Besitzer von dem und dem Werk oder von der Mona Lisa oder...
Aber auch nur, weil es ein Spekulationsmarkt ist.
Ja, also ich sage mal so, ich vergleiche das immer so, wenn Picasso einen Druck von einem Bild angefertigt hat, und dann hat er, was weiß ich, 50 Drucke angefertigt. Die sind dann viel wert, weil die von ihm sind. Wenn, sobald Picasso dann die Druckerei verlässt, der Drucker dahin geht und dann einfach nochmal 100 Stück davon macht, dann wären das keine Original-Picasso's mehr. Also, und das ist eben was, was durch NFT sozusagen sichergestellt werden soll. Das ist jeweils von diesem einzelnen Künstler oder der Künstlerin gemacht worden. Und es ist eben nicht nur eine direkte Kopie, die mehr oder weniger komplett identisch ist, bis auf vielleicht den Zeitstempel. Ich meine, da gab es natürlich jetzt auch so Vorfälle, Stichwort Sleepminting, wo Leute einfach sich in die Wallets von KünstlerInnen reingeschlichen haben und quasi ohne deren Wissen in deren Namen Kunstwerke herausgegeben haben und sich selber verkauft haben. Solche Fälschungen, die sind auch schon passiert.
Die Niedertracht des Menschen kennt keine Grenzen.
Es ist für mich völlig faszinierend, was für eine wie abstrakt Besitz in dem Fall geworden ist. Also es kann jeder kopieren, es sind dieselben Bits, aber ich kann sagen, es ist meins. Und dafür gebe ich irgendwie zweistellige Millionenbeträge aus.
Aber wie stehst du denn selber dazu, Max? Weil die, was ich am Anfang vorgelesen habe, hast du ja wirklich gesagt, du hast dich gegen potenzielle Auktionsgewinne abgesichert. Das ist ja das Antithema. Findest du das eigentlich eine coole Idee? Oder eigentlich denkst du, das muss angezündet werden und gehört weg?
Also das Letzte finde ich natürlich einfach direkt schon mal sehr sympathisch. Ich bin da sehr, sehr, sehr gespalten, was das angeht. Also zum einen glaube ich, pardon jetzt, irgendwas wollte ich gerade vorsagen, das ist mir jetzt ein Fall, ich muss mir mal überlegen. Also zum einen fand ich es natürlich total absurd, auch die erste Reaktion, die jeder hatte, wieder bezahlt jemand für ein rein digitales Bild so viel Geld. Das kann doch gar nicht wahr sein, das ist da absolut der Bullshit, was da für Millionen weggeht, das kann ich mir mit einem Rechtsklick runterladen, hab dasselbe und kann dann sagen, guck, ich hab sie auch auf meinem PC drauf. Also das wirkt erstmal total absurd. Und andererseits, das ist jetzt nur mal am Rande, könnte das sogar so eine kleine Rettung sein für dieses kapitalistische Versprechen des endlosen Wirtschaftswachstums trotz begrenzter Ressourcen. Also das ist ja, sind ja in den allermeisten Fällen sind das ja auch Leute, die mit Krypto viel Geld gemacht haben, die gerade dort die Preise extrem hoch treiben. Also in dem konkreten Fall von dem Beeple-Werk, das dort für 69 Millionen weggegangen ist, wird mindestens unterstellt, dass der Käufer, der dieses Werk so teuer gekauft hat, dass der gleichzeitig schon eine Kollektion von Beeple besaß und aus dieser Kollektion selber wieder eine Mehrwährung gemacht hat, an der man Anteile kaufen konnte, an der wiederum Beeple selber mit Anteilen beteiligt war. Das bedeutet, der Käufer, der dort 69 Millionen bezahlt hat, der war eigentlich traurig, dass er nicht noch mehr bezahlen durfte, weil es ihm darum ging, den Preis unterstellterweise so hoch wie möglich zu treiben, weil dadurch natürlich auch die anderen Kunstwerke, die er in seiner Sammlung besaß, noch mehr Geld wert gewesen wären. Man muss auch irgendwo vielleicht auch ein bisschen dankbar sein, dass die Leute, die da ihre Krypto-Milliarden verdient haben, die eben dann in digitale Kunst irgendwo, wo es keinen anderen stört, reinschieben, als sich zum Beispiel auf einmal Schrippen zu kaufen, weil ansonsten plötzlich die Schrippen zwei Euro kosten würden oder noch mehr, wenn die diese Kohle, die die da machen, auf einmal in den normalen Geldmarkt reinschieben würden. Irgendwie ist es gut, dass diese absurden Krypto-Gewinne auch im Kryptomarkt bleiben. Für mich persönlich, also ich hatte wie gesagt diese allererste Reaktion, das ist doch total absurd, was da läuft, und wollte dann auch entsprechende Kunstwerke machen oder da entsprechendes Statement zugeben. Das allererste, was ich gemacht hatte, war, was sich da für mich abzeichnet, ist zum einen dieses Auseinanderklatschen, von was ist etwas wert und was ist der Preis. Also eine digitale Datei, die man beliebig kopieren kann, die ist für mich nichts wert. Die Arbeit dahinter, die zu erstellen, die ist auf jeden Fall was wert, aber die Datei da selber, wüsste ich nicht, warum man für eine gratis erstellte Kopie was bezahlen müsste eigentlich. Und gleichzeitig sind da so krasse Preise für bezahlt. Deswegen war mein allererstes Kunstwerk, was ich da gemacht habe, ein einzelner, transparenter Pixel. Aber ich dachte, okay, was ist das Kunstwerk, das einfach das am allerwenigsten wert sein müsste, weil einfach so wenig wie möglich drinsteckt, was so wenig wie möglich überhaupt existiert. Und das ist ein Bild von Einmal-Ein-Pixel-Abmessung und ohne irgendeine Farbe. Und das habe ich so als Statement dann auch irgendwo bei OpenSea, auf so einer Plattform gemintet, einfach um diese Absurdität, diesen Unterschied zwischen Wert und Preis darzustellen. Habe dabei erschreckenderweise festgestellt oder nachher ausgerechnet, dass dieses Ding dann theoretisch, also diese einzelne Aktion, über 100 Kilogramm CO2 verursacht haben soll, rein rechnerisch. Wenn man den Berechnungen glauben kann, was natürlich auch einfach katastrophal ist. Man muss natürlich da auch immer fairerweise unterscheiden zwischen dem CO2-Ausstoß von Blockchain, Krypto, NFT und dem Energieverbrauch. Weil das Energieverbrauch mit einem CO2-Ausstoß korreliert, ist zum Teil auch einfach immer noch ein Versagen der Politik, die den Wandel zu erneuerbaren Energien nicht geschafft hat, wenn wir alle unsere Energie aus Ökostrom kriegen würden.
Das ginge aber schneller, wenn wir nicht Energie für Blockchain ausgeben würden. Das ist ja auch ein Zeltbeschluss.
Wie meinst du das?
Naja, pass auf. Das Umstellen auf erneuerbare Energien fordert ja, dass wir Quellen für erneuerbare Energien schaffen, dass wir Solarzellen aufstellen, Windkrafträder aufstellen usw. In dem Moment, wo du mehr Energie verbrauchst, als du eigentlich benötigen würdest ohne Blockchain, machst es halt schwerer, auf erneuerbare Energien umzustellen. Du kannst nicht auf der einen Seite den Energieverbrauch mit der Schaufel zum Fenster rauswerfen. Auf der anderen Seite sagen, die Politik hat es nicht geschafft, erneuerbare Energien einzuführen. Das ist schon so.
Das erfordert auch Energiesparen. Nein, nein, stopp. Aber das dann zu sagen, wir haben zu wenig erneuerbare Energie, weil Blockchain, das ist schon auch kurz gegriffen. Da kannst du auch sagen, wir müssen nicht alle Auto fahren, wir müssen nicht alle fliegen und so weiter und so fort.
Das ist richtig, aber zu sagen, na ja, gut, auf Blockchain verzichten wir jetzt nicht, aber wofür dann? Also dann kommt der nächste und sagt, auf Auto fahren verzichten wir nicht. Der nächste kommt und sagt, auf Fliegen verzichten wir nicht. Also eine Umstellung auf eine CO2-freie Wirtschaft erfordert auch Energiesparen. Und an der Stelle muss man einfach den Sinn und den Unsinn von Energieverbrauch hinterfragen. Und das betrifft ein Auto genauso wie eine Blockchain.
Da hast du absolut recht. Ich meine nur, wenn wir von Anfang an immer schon nur erneuerbare Energien benutzt hätten, dann gäbe es keine Diskussion über einen CO2-Ausstoß von NFT. Das wollte ich nur sagen.
Nee, weißt du, worüber wir dann diskutieren würden? Über Blackouts wegen mangelnder Energieversorgung. Also ich denke, diesen Punkt werden wir auch noch erreichen.
Dann sprechen wir aber nicht unbedingt über den Energieverbrauch von NFT, sondern eher um den Anstieg, der da durch die vermehrte Nutzung oder durch die brunghaft vermehrte Nutzung jetzt gerade, also dass jetzt die Infrastrukturen da nicht entsprechend hinterherziehen. Das kann man jetzt nur bedingt den Kryptowährungen oder den NFTs jetzt selber vorwerfen.
Ich würde aber nochmal bei den NFTs landen wollen, weil mir scheint, das ist ein Thema, ein Metathema, das sich bei Blockchain wiederholt ist. Es wird auf gesellschaftliche Probleme draufgeworfen, klärt diese nicht, führt aber dazu, dass Leute, die eh gut im Spekulieren sind, spekulieren, also der Teufelscheiß auf den größten Haufen, konkret. Vor allen Dingen profitieren von NFTs Spekulateure. Es hilft den Künstlerinnen nichts und es maskiert damit ein Problem auf eine liberale, libertäre Art und Weise, eine neoliberale Art und Weise. Im Prinzip sind wir als Gesellschaft daran interessiert, Künstlerinnen zu haben. Diese Künstlerinnen sollen auch leben können und das möglichst auch gut. Weil es eben kein System gibt, was das gewährleistet, führt das jetzt dazu, dass es NFTs gibt, die aber dann nicht das Problem klären, nämlich dass Künstlerinnen gut davon leben können. Also ein paar ja, aber viele eben auch nicht, wie du gesagt hast. Dafür ist der Spekulationsmarkt wieder um ein weiteres Spekulationsobjekt gestiegen.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also ich sag mal so, auch mit NFT ist da immer noch eine Monopolisierung gegeben. Das heißt, die Leute, die vorher mit digitaler Kunst oder anderer Kunst gut verdient haben, die verdienen auch mit NFT mehr. Aber grundsätzlich ist die Schere zwischen den Gutverdienenden und den Nichtsverdienenden kleiner geworden oder ist aktuell kleiner gewesen. Also da gibt es ganz, ganz viele Leute, die vorher auch noch nie irgendetwas mit Kunst verdient hatten und plötzlich am NFT-Markt etwas verkaufen konnten, selbst wenn es nur daran lag, dass überreiche Spekulanten plötzlich sinnlos deren Kunst gekauft haben.
Also das Problem, das ich so ein bisschen damit habe, zum einen mit Zehntum gab es schon immer. Also Leute mit zu viel Geld haben schon immer die Kunst gefördert. Das ist ja im Prinzip auch gut und richtig. Aber das ist so ein bisschen das The Winner Takes It All Prinzip. Oder wie die FDP sagen würde, Chancengleichheit. Es kann halt jeder mit der gleichen Chance im Lotto gewinnen. In der Praxis trifft das aber nicht alle, sondern es trifft ein paar. Die schwimmen dann im Geld und der Rest hat auch wieder keine Kohle. Vom Ansatz her gefällt mir einfach so etwas wie Patreon zum Supporten von Künstlern besser. Jeder tut seine zwei Euro im Topf im Monat. Wenn sich genügend Leute finden, die Kunst gut finden, kann man davon auch leben. Bei einem NFT musst du halt den einen finden, der dir das dann komplett auszahlt für dieses eine Kunstwerk anstatt dass tausend Leute sagen, das finde ich geil, da schmeiße ich was in den Hut für. Mich stört dieses überspitzte, mit Zehntum, Milliardäre, leisten es sich bestimmte Künstler und alles, was damit einhergeht, irgendwie hip zu sein, sich zu zeigen und so weiter und so fort. Das ist, glaube ich, ganz enorm. Meiner Meinung nach nicht der beste Ansatz, um Kunst zu fördern, Künstler zu fördern.
Also ich komme nicht auf einen grünen Zweig, kann man das, glaube ich, zusammenfassen, weil alles, was mit Blockchain zu tun hat und NFTs auch, ist immer sozusagen sehr hart hinterfragbar. Und ja, das hat vielleicht eine Berechtigung. Aber bei allen Beispielen, die wir heute verhandelt haben, frage ich mich immer, würde das auch so existieren ohne die Spekulation dahinter? Also ohne eben dieses Scam-System, kann man fast schon sagen, wo es halt dann nur darum geht, eine künstliche Knappheit eigentlich zu erzeugen und Ressourcen zu verschwenden. Also im Prinzip bezahlen wir, wir jetzt als Welt, in Energie und Chip-Knappheit, dass Leute spekulieren können. Und das, also mich spricht das persönlich nicht an. Falls ihr das anders seht, könnt ihr es gerne, oder auch genauso, könnt ihr es gerne in die Kommentare schreiben. Ich würde jetzt noch eine Abschlussrunde machen wollen und jedem von euch eine Frage in zwei Teilen stellen. Nämlich, sollte Blockchain weggehen und wird Blockchain weggehen? Peter?
Ja und ja.
Aber warum?
Ich bin jetzt berühmt dafür, mich hier kurz zu fassen. Ja, also sollte, sollte Blockchain weggehen. Also vielleicht gibt es irgendwo einen Endwendungsfall, der tatsächlich Sinn ergibt, den ich dann auch unterschreiben würde und um das auch nochmal klar zu sagen, ich finde die Technologie als solche durchaus spannend. Also da haben sich schlaue Leute schlaue Gedanken gemacht, das ist interessant, allerdings eher von einem akademischen Standpunkt heraus. Also ich finde, wie gesagt, in der freien Welt da draußen habe ich immer noch nichts gesehen, was mich irgendwie überzeugt und so die ganz rapiden Nachteile, die hatten wir jetzt alle schon durchdekliniert, insbesondere was die Energieverschwendung angeht. Und ich bin auch bei Andreas, dass mir so ein Patreon-System vom Grundsatz her besser gefällt als wieder eine Blockchain. Und ich habe halt immer den Eindruck, dass Dinge mit Zwang auf Blockchain gehievt werden, weil es halt gerade geht und Leute verzweifelt irgendeine Anwendungsweise suchen, mit dem man dann wiederum Venture Capital einsammeln kann. Und das führt irgendwie zunächst eigentlich nur zu Ressourcenverschwendung. Das ist eben nicht der Meinung, dass sie gehen sollte. Und ich glaube, dass sie geht, weil sich dieses Memen, dass Blockchain total sicher ist und alles besser macht, bemerkenswert penetrant hält bis jetzt. Aber jedes Memen hat seine Zeit und das wird dafür auch gelten. Also ich gehe davon aus, dass ich da die, also ich merke das auch schon so ein bisschen im politischen und Industriebereich, dann lichtet sich ein wenig so der Himmel. Also ich denke, das Memen ist gerade wieder am Absterben und ich glaube, das wird deswegen auch gehen.
Aber das ist zu sagen, das gilt für die Verbreitung der Idee, Blockchain, Bitcoin wird wahrscheinlich bleiben und ist ja real, oder?
Ja, ich denke schon. Also Bitcoin wird uns auf jeden Fall noch ein Weilchen begleiten. Ich würde mir nicht zutrauen zu mutmaßen, wie das denn mit dem Kurs aussehen wird. Ich würde mir wünschen, dass sich das wieder ein bisschen normalisiert und zurückgeht. Und ich denke, es wird ein permanenter Randeffekt werden. Mal gucken.
Andreas?
Ich finde, also tatsächlich ist Blockchain auch eine faszinierende Technologie, aber auch Atombomben sind eine faszinierende Technologie. Und ich glaube nicht, dass es sie geben sollte auf unserem Planeten. Also insbesondere Proof of Work muss verschwinden. Das ist ein Riesenproblem, ist eine Riesenumweltsäure. Es wird nicht besser werden. Das wird uns das Klimakosten, es wird uns im Kopf einen Kragen bringen. Das muss verschwinden. Ich mag nicht vorherzusagen, ob eine der alternativen Technologien die Möglichkeit hat, da ersatz zu sein. Also Festplattenplatz ist keine Alternative, weil auch der kostet Ressourcen. Also alles, was sozusagen mit dem Horden physischer Ressourcen zu tun hat, ist meines Erachtens ungeeignet. Vielleicht hat Proof of Stake eine Chance. Ich habe einen Algorithmus gesehen, der relativ interessant probabilistisch arbeitet. Wenn man eine Münze der Währung in der Tasche hat, ist es sozusagen ein Ticket für die Lotterie, mitten in der Blockchain teilnehmen zu dürfen. Und wenn man halt gerade online ist, dann darf man auch mitmachen und kriegt ausgezahlt. Das kann funktionieren. Mit Sicherheit gibt es Anwendungen, die im internationalen Warenverkehr über reine Spekulationen hinausgehen. Die habe ich, glaube ich, erwähnt. Das wird auch nicht weggehen. Auch ein Fass, das wir heute nicht aufmachen wollen mit der Drogenlegalisierung, aber wird zu viel mit der Kopf behalten. Was ich hoffe, ist, dass der Hype weggeht. Und was ich hoffe, dass, ich denke, das wird es auch, dieses irgendwie, naja, ich habe Blockchain als Hammer, also sieht jedes Problem bei einem Nagel aus, weggeht. Es gibt bessere verteilte Datenbanken, es gibt bessere Mechanismen, um Hashes über Daten zu bilden. Und für die allermeisten Fälle gibt es auch bessere Konsensalgorithmen.
Also ich glaube, dass Blockchain in unserer technologisierten und kapitalistischen Welt so die zweitbeste Lösung ist, die wir haben. Und mich fasziniert vor allem diese Idee des Dezertalisierten. Und ich glaube, da wird noch viel kommen in Richtung, also das Potenzial von Smart Contracting wird noch viel stärker mal ausgenutzt werden. Vor allem, wenn es auch weggeht von diesen ganzen Spekulativen, wenn der ganze Energieverbrauch mal reduziert wird, wenn man sich dann mal damit befasst, wie man eben auch politische Entscheidungsprozesse damit unterstützen kann. Und sei es jetzt nicht nur darum, dass, also ich glaube nicht unbedingt, dass die Technologie Blockchain bestehen bleibt, aber ich glaube, dass sie wertvolle Impulse für neue Gedanken liefern wird in Richtung Dezentralisierung. Und dass es dann zu so einem Umdecken kommt, zu dem, was eben angesprochen wurde, Patreon, sowas in die Richtung. Das ist ja auch nur ein Schritt in die Richtung, dass alle Leute einfach cool miteinander sind, keiner mehr spekulieren muss, weil jeder dem anderen das Essen gibt, was er braucht. Darüber reden wir, da wollen wir eigentlich hin. Und ich glaube, in die Richtung kann uns Blockchain gedanklich ein bisschen bringen, deswegen glaube ich, im Moment Strom für die Blockchain ist power to the people.
Okay, ich glaube, viel weiter auseinander sind wir selten mal im Chaosradio geendet. Und ich würde das gerne an dieser Stelle einfach so stehen lassen. Mich bei euch bedanken, Max, Peter und Andreas, dass ihr heute da wart. Vielen Dank, Dankeschön. Und bei euch, liebe Hörerinnen, dass ihr so geduldig zugehört habt und lasst uns wie gesagt gerne wissen, was ihr von dem Thema habt. Ich bin sehr gespannt. Oft ist das ja so in der Chaosradio-Bubble, dass das Themen, sagen wir mal, aus einer eindeutigen Perspektive besetzt sind, wie es hier ist, würde mich sehr interessieren. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter, mir bleibt nur noch, mich zu verabschieden, ganz ohne Blockchain und zu sagen, lasst sie nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.